ordenemos todas estas fracciones
impropia sin números mixtos
ok queremos hacer una lista donde estén
ordenados estos números de tal forma que
el más chico esté a la izquierda y luego
esté el siguiente más chico y así hasta
llegar al más grande y bueno para
compararlos y saber cuál es más grande
que cuál hay dos formas de hacer esto
una es convertir todos estos números a
fracciones impropias y compararlos como
fracciones impropias o también podemos
convertir todos estos números a números
mixtos y ya que están todos como números
mixtos compararlos bueno a mí me parece
que esa es la forma con la que yo quiero
empezar cambiando todos los números en
números mixtos y vamos a ver qué tal
funciona eso aunque entonces vamos a
escribirlos toda esta lista de números
como números mixtos
empecemos con siete tercios siete entre
tres estados o sea el tres cabe dos
veces dentro de siete y nos deja un
residuo de 1 así es que el siete tercios
son dos enteros y un tercio
ahora vamos con cuatro enteros y un
medio pues éste ya está escrito como un
número mixto no entonces nada más vamos
a copiarlo aquí cuatro enteros y un
medio ahora vamos con cuatro tercios
cuatro entre tres es un entero y nos
sobra uno así es que tenemos un tercio y
ahora uno y dos quintos también está
escrito como un número mixto así es que
nada más lo copiamos dos quintos y 17-15
amos pues 17 entre 15 cae una sola vez
y de residuo nos quedan dos entonces
tenemos aquí 215 a vos muy bien entonces
aquí nada más con darle una ojeada
rápida a esta lista pues ya sabemos
exactamente cuál es el número más grande
de la lista no lo sé entre todos estos
enteros
este es el entero más grande entonces
este es el número más grande
así es que pues vamos a escribirlo por
aquí tenemos que el número más grande es
cuatro y un medio y se puede ver cuál es
el siguiente número más grande
definitivamente dos es más grande que
estos otros tres números entonces el
siguiente número más grande es dos
enteros y un tercio pero ahora nos
encontramos con el problema de que los
otros tres números tienen exactamente
mismo entero la misma parte entera
entonces cuál de estos tres números es
más grande depende de la fracción como
tenemos distintos denominadores no las
podemos comparar directamente tenemos
que transformar estas fracciones para
que tengan un común denominador y
entonces si las podamos comparar y cuál
es el mejor como un denominador pues ese
es el mínimo común múltiplo entre 35 y
15 pero resulta que tanto el 3 como y 5
dividen al 15 o sea 3 por 5 es 15
entonces el mejor común denominador que
se nos pueda ocurrir va a ser 15 así es
que vamos a transformar este número
mixto para que su fracción tenga como
denominador a 15 así es que vamos a
tener un 1 y quién sabe cuántos 15 a vos
a ver cuántos 15 a 2 pues para
transformar este denominador en un 15
tenemos que multiplicar a este 3 por 5
entonces tenemos que multiplicar este
numerador por 5 y 1 por 5 son 5
ahora transformando este número mixto
vamos a tener un entero y quién sabe
cuántos 15 a 25 porque me da 15 5 por 3
me da 15 entonces tenemos que
multiplicar el numerador por 3 y 2 por 3
son 6 así es que aquí va un 6 este
número ha terminado siendo un 1 y quién
sabe cuántos 15 bosh a este ya está
escrito como un 1 y algunos 15 años o
sea que aquí nada más va a un 2 y ahora
sí ahora sí ya podemos comparar estos
números entonces de estas fracciones
cuál es la más grande pues 615 a vos no
entonces de estos números el más grande
es uno y
6 15 años el siguiente más grandes 15 15
a 21 y 5 15 a vos y hasta el último el
más pequeño resultó ser 12 15 21 y 215 a
vos
ok ahora sí ya ahora tenemos toda esta
lista de números desde el más chiquito
hasta el más grandote ahora tal vez sea
una muy buena idea escribir esta lista
tal cual como nos la dieron aquí porque
entonces a ver 1 y 2 15 a vos ese nos lo
dieron con 1 17 15 años entonces aquí
deberemos escribir 17 15 ago el 15 15 a
vos en realidad era uno y un tercio y es
este color o sea nos lo dieron como
cuatro tercios
cuatro tercios el 1 y 6 15 años era uno
y dos quintos y este si nos lo dieron
como uno y dos quintos en su forma de
número mixto uno y dos quintos ahora
este amarillo es dos y un tercio y ese
es el primer número que convertimos en
una fracción mixta o sea siete tercios
siete tercios y aquí el cuatro y un
medio cuatro y un medio nos lo dieron
como cuatro y un medio sea cuatro y un
medio bien esta es la lista que
realmente necesitábamos
otra cosa que pudimos haber hecho es en
lugar de convertir todos estos números
en números mixtos
pudimos haber convertido todos estos
números a fracciones impropias y ya que
están todos como fracciones impropias
compararlos y ordenarlos entonces si
quisiéramos hacer eso pues este siete
tercios lo dejaríamos tal cual como
siete tercios porque ya es una fracción
impropia este cuatro y un medio pues
tenemos cuatro por 2 819 medios a ver
este 4 enteros si lo queremos convertir
en una fracción impropia con denominador
2 pues eso nos queda en 8 medios más
este un medio que ya teníamos entonces
nos quedan 9 medios
nueve medios que la forma automatizada
para hacer esto es agarrar el entero 4
multiplicarlo por el denominador y sumar
la el numerador o sea 4 por 2 819 medios
ok aquí este cuatro tercios ya es una
fracción impropia cuatro tercios este
uno y dos quintos este uno en realidad
son cinco quintos entonces ya que
tenemos cinco quintos le sumamos dos
quintos y nos queda 527 quintos
siete quintos y 17 15 a los 17 que
iniciamos y ya que todos los números de
la lista están escritos como fracciones
impropias
entonces para compararlos y poderlos
ordenar lo que tenemos que hacer es
hacer que todos ellos tengan el mismo
denominador
tenemos que encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo de todos estos denominadores y
convertir todas estas fracciones a
fracciones equivalentes que tengan ese
denominador como vimos cuando estábamos
escribiendo estas fracciones el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 3 5 y 15 es 15
ahora
ese no es un múltiplo de 2 entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es multiplicar 15 por
2 y ese sí es un múltiplo de todos estos
números de hecho es el mínimo común
múltiplo de estos números
entonces vamos a transformar todas estas
fracciones a fracciones equivalentes que
tengan denominador 30 cuc y denominador
30 y para pasar de tres a 30 tenemos que
multiplicar el denominador por 10
entonces también tenemos que multiplicar
el numerador por 10 o sea aquí tiene que
ir un 70 ahora para cambiar nueve medios
por una fracción equivalente con
denominador treinta pues tenemos que
multiplicar dos por 1530 y entonces
tenemos que multiplicar el 9 por 15 y 9
por 15 135 135 ok cuatro tercios para
transformarlo en una fracción
equivalente con denominador treinta pues
nada más tenemos que multiplicar
numerador y denominador por 10 o sea
aquí nos va a quedar 47 quintos
5 por 6 búsqueda 30 entonces 7 por 6 42
y 15 por 230 entonces 17 por 27 por 2 14
y llevamos 12 por 12 + 13 o sea 34 y
ahora sí ya podemos ordenar más chicos
más grandes aunque hay quien aquí es el
número más grande pues nada más nos
tenemos que fijar en los numeradores
porque todos los denominadores son el
mismo todas las rebanadas de los
pasteles son exactamente del mismo
tamaño porque cada parte lo estamos
viviendo en 30 pedacitos iguales en
todas estas fracciones entonces nos
fijamos cuál es el numerador más grande
y es éste el numerador más grande o sea
que el número más grande es 135 30 vos
el siguiente número más grande es 70 así
es que aquí en segundo lugar nos queda
el 70
en davos y después podemos buscar cuál
es el número más chico y el número más
chico entre estos es el 34 o sea que
aquí el número más chico son 34 30 bosch
y bueno que el lugar va aquí va el
segundo más chico o sea 40 30 240 30 vos
y finalmente qué número va aquí pues el
único que falta osea 42 30 vos 42 30 vos
ok
esta fue la forma en la que ordenamos en
esta lista convirtiéndolo todo a
fracciones impropias y si convertimos
cada uno de estos números a su valor
original a la forma en la que nos la
dieron originalmente entonces vamos a
obtener exactamente el mismo orden que
nos dio con los números mixtos de hecho
se puede ver con los colores no sea
primero naranja luego rosa verde
amarillo y azul